Thank You gentleman from Massachusetts
mr. speaker for the purpose of debate
only I yield three minutes to the
gentleman from Vermont mr. Sanders
gentleman from Vermont is recognized for
three minutes without objection so
ordered I thank the gentleman for
yielding mr. speaker in 1984 as part of
the deregulation swindle pushed by the
Reagan administration and some members
of Congress the government withdrew its
rate protection for cable TV consumers
despite the fact that in community after
community in Vermont and throughout this
country there is no competition between
different companies that monopolies
exist the government said to the cable
television industry you can raise your
rates as high as you want you can
squeeze the consumer as hard as you want
and what have been the results the
General Accounting Office determined the
cable TV rates on the national level
increased 61 percent from November 1986
to April 91 and in recent years cable TV
rates have gone up even faster they're
going up off the wall mr. speaker
President Reagan and members of the
Congress deregulated the Savings and
Loan industry and the taxpayers of this
country will be paying hundreds of
billions of dollars in additional taxes
as a result President Reagan and members
of this Congress deregulated the cable
TV industry and consumers from one end
of this country to the other are paying
billions more than they should be paying
in rates for the basic tier of cable TV
services mr. speaker it is not
acceptable to me that in my own state of
Vermont according to the national
association of broadcasters rates for
similar channel offerings since 1986
have gone up by fifty-eight percent in
bennington a hundred and twenty-three
percent in my pee liya a hundred and ten
percent in st. Johnsbury thirty-four
percent in Burlington and thirty-four
percent Rutland mr. speaker where
competition does not exist
ah Polly is in place the government has
a legitimate right to make certain that
citizens especially our elderly citizens
unlimited incomes can receive basic
cable TV service at a rate they can
afford that's a right of the people mr.
speaker last year I held hearings of
Vermont on this issue and in my view the
people of Vermont the people of America
want regulatory protection they want
some control on the escalating costs the
basic rates for cable TV and this
legislation begins the process I urge
support for the rule and support for the
entire legislation I yield back the
balance of my time